alors justement vous vous êtes une
victime collatérale de la guerre
économique ou une victime collatérale de
la lutte anti-corruption année deux
victimes je ne suis pas du tout une
victime ce qui se passe dans la sphère
alstom c'est que en 2003 effectivement
il ya cette affaire en indonésie donc à
partir de cette affaire en inde
indonésie
les étasuniens ont tiré le film sur la
pelote de laine et ont découvert en fait
tous les faits de corruption que le
groupe avait fait un peu partout dans le
monde pendant une quinzaine d'années
il faut savoir que
lutter contre la corruption bien
évidemment tout le monde est d'accord
pour prolonger des collections ce qu'il
faut voir c'est plutôt la symétrie des
sanctions prises par les états unis
contre les entreprises qui sont accusés
de corruption
et là on voit une énorme asymétrie entre
les poursuites contre leurs propres et
entreprises et pour sept cantons
entreprises étrangères notamment
européennes
vous faites la liste par exemple j'ai
mis un peu de temps de
regardez un peu tout ça donc si vous
faites la liste des entreprises qui ont
payé par exemple plus de 100 millions de
dollars d'amendé au titre de cette loi
f6 pied vous rendez compte qu'il ya 32
et sur 709 vous n'avez 19 européenne dès
que cette entreprise américaine en fait
en pourcentage des entreprises
américaines payent moins de 20% des
amendes aux titres de leurs propres lois
anti corruption
et vous si vous prenez secteur
d'activité particulier on parlera de
d'airbus mais on peut parler de la
production d'électricité vous rendez
compte par exemple que tous les
concurrents de l'entreprise américaine
dans le secteur de la production
d'électricité ce soit abb siemens alstom
itachi sont tous passés passer par les
fourches caudines du fcp tout le monde a
écopé d'amendés
vous prenez leurs équivalents aux états
unis en depuis 1977 les états unis n'ont
pas santé une seule société dans la
production électricité domestique
vous voyez une asymétrie des sanctions
parce que tout le monde et concurrents
sur les mêmes marchés
tout le monde se promène appels d'offres
et ya pas de miracle
[Musique]